in the divergent world once you leave
the nest there is no going back we're
talking intense boot camps with muay
thai fighters 66 foot free falls and a
zip line that runs through all of
downtown chicago you have to decide if
you're gonna stick with the way you were
raised or listen to your own internal
compass we're going to be diving out of
that nest and going deep into the
complex world of divergent number one
what good would an action movie be
without a badass seven-story jump into
oblivion alicia vella bailly who doubles
for shailene woodley hasn't done a lot
of high falls in her stunt career so in
preparation for her jump they started
her at 40 feet to 50 all the way up to
her final 66 foot jump that airbag looks
like a little cell phone down below when
you're jumping off the building number
two to prepare for their roles the
diverging cast had to endure a grueling
three-week long boot camp in chicago the
director neil berger wanted to make sure
they had the military side of their
performance down packed it was a painful
process for the actors as they were
trained by army veterans and
professional muay thai fighters among
all the intense physical training
shailene also had to be trained in
firearms and knife throwing
number three obviously you have to get
in a few practice rounds before jumping
onto a moving train right well
unfortunately shailene was the only cast
member that didn't get a chance to
rehearse before attempting the jump the
train which was built completely by the
special effects team is pulled by an
endless so essentially if she missed the
first jump they could bring it right
back around
number four one thing you probably
didn't know was that shaylene woodley's
butt did not make the final cut theo
james who plays four decided the best
way to make light of he and shailene's
romantic scene was to pull down her
pants right in the middle of filming i
pulled chase pants down on the ferris
wheel
but you actually took it very well she
said it completely threw her off though
luckily not the ferris wheel
number five shaneley woodley gets the
ride of her life through downtown
chicago on a zip line traveling at 30
miles per hour she actually describes
herself as not afraid of heights but
afraid of falling so this was a great
opportunity for her to face her fears i
get such an adrenaline rush from
completing something that i didn't think
i could complete do you think you'd be
brave enough to fly through all of
downtown chicago on a zip line let us
know in the comments number six
speaking of bravery do you remember the
scene where tris and four walked on a
flimsy high wire between two skyscrapers
yeah that was made by computers so it
has to be computer generated from
scratch but it has to look exactly like
you took a photograph of those buildings
with lidar scanning and extensive
texture photography they were able to
create an exact replica of the two
skyscrapers and make it look like tris
and four were really one thousand feet
in the air
number seven neil berger wanted a unique
fighting style portrayed in the film
that no one had ever seen before what
they ended up coming up with was a
peek-a-boo fighting guard as well as a
signature hammer fist the fight
choreographer jj perry wanted the
actor's progression to be shown on
camera in the first training scene where
triss fights molly that is their actual
first day of training he wanted it to be
clear how far everyone progressed by the
end of the film number eight neil berger
had been a fan of shailene woodley ever
since he saw her in the descendants when
he was thinking about triss's qualities
he naturally landed on shailene to play
her but she had this incredible
combination of vulnerability and
rebelliousness but because shailene was
such a powerful force they struggled to
find someone to play her counterpart for
we read a number of people and they were
really good actors but sometimes they
just didn't fit with her or sometimes
she kind of would roll right over them
they really went through the ringer
trying to find someone who could keep up
with shailene that is until theo james
walked in so they had this incredible
reading together and we knew right away
that he was the guy number nine the pit
one of the most important and utilized
set pieces in the entire film was built
from the ground up by the art department
and set design the idea originated after
seeing pictures of a quarry in colorado
because the entire pit was handmade they
really had to focus on getting a
textural finish that looked realistic on
camera painters and plasterers have to
achieve a texture and finish that works
really well for close up and really well
from a long way away though most of the
pit was constructed of plaster the fight
coordinators had to strategically place
foam pads onto the walls where the
fights took place so no one would
actually get hurt being bashed into them
do you think you'd be able to go back
and spot them
number 10 the birth of one of the five
factions came from neil berger's visit
to willis tower at the time known as
sears tower i looked down just to the
south of it and i saw this patch of
green and i said that's where abnegation
should be immediately after they started
building faction houses right in the
middle of chicago they were so
beautifully done residents of the city
were actually wondering if they could
buy them number 11. veronica roth the
author of the divergent series got to
make a cameo in the film as a dauntless
initiate because this was her first time
in front of the camera she had a few
on-screen jitters she was super nervous
because she really can't act i didn't
want to mess it up i didn't want to be
like the one weak link in the chain well
don't worry veronica there was not a
single weak link in this film great job
number 12. everything in the divergent
world has meaning behind it even the
characters tattoos after they were
designed they were printed on plexiglas
before being presented to the actors
four's iconic back tattoo spoke to theo
because of its aggressiveness and sense
of meaning it's so aggressive that it
takes several hours just to apply number
13. as we all know divergent is full of
beautiful compelling visual effects but
what you may not know is how much they
had to work around the city of chicago
itself they had to get rid of things
that seem minute like cars traffic
lights and pedestrians in order to
create a setting that looks different
and futuristic but not so futuristic
that it's unbelievable which brings us
to our next topic number 14 because
divergent is set in a dystopian
futuristic world they couldn't just
shoot on the streets of chicago and call
it a day they had to transform and
repurpose every inch of the city while
still trying to maintain its
authenticity we were using the locations
that were there and then transforming
them neil berger describes the
redecorating of chicago streets as an
enormous undertaking who knew something
as simple as a street light could bring
us back to 2014.
number 15. as i'm sure you can imagine
there were quite a few onset injuries in
the making of divergent one in
particular you might not be aware of was
the vicious attack on zoe kravitz by
shailene's trailer door she made it out
alive but she did have to get eight
stitches across her nose not only that
but according to zoe shailene got to
take home a battle scar of her own shae
at one point fell doing a stunt on her
own and she cut her face so there we
have it all the blood sweat tears and
movie magic involved in the making of
divergent veronica roth's beautiful
trilogy was brought to life by a
dedicated cast crew and of course the
city of chicago what was your favorite
behind the scenes moment
[Music]